dan haggis s'est mis directement à dos
l'association c'est à dire yt il a dit
ce qu'il pensait des associations alors
est-ce qu'on est d'accord avec nagui ou
pas il y en a qui disent qu'il a pété
les plombs d'autres qui disent qu'il a
raison dites nous ce que vous en pensez
la guillette il pétait les plombs orgue
à l'idée de pouvoir soutenir une
recherche mais d'éviter qu'elle soit
faite sur les animaux et justement c'est
l'idéal mais c'est ça mais c'était la
question c'est est ce que c'est possible
c'est tout quand il s'agit de sauver un
enfant et qu'il y à des animaux qui sont
déjà atteints d'une forme de myopathie
dire qu on essaye on fait des essais
cliniques sur ces animaux atteints de
myopathie
ça ne me choque pas parce que je cherche
un des scientifiques qui font tout pour
éviter la souffrance absolument nuit
recherche en fait elles peuvent être
faussés puisqu'une fois sur les humains
donc c'est ça aussi le problème de
l'échec
alors oui alors il ay la donne son avis
moi j'aime bien aussi les animateurs
relativité wii s'offre à eux mais dites
la vérité de dire vraiment ce que vous
en pensez
pour vous nagui a pété un plomb ce qui
est vraiment minable c'est que hissé à
l'avance pour quelle association joue
quel joueur donc à la limite il aurait
pu dire à joyce jonathan avant je n'aime
pas cette assoc
je ne veux pas que tu la soutiennent
j'en sais rien ce qu'il veut en
coulisses mais qu'il a attendu qu'elle
soit là la pauvre elle chante elle vient
défendre une association pour la mettre
mal devant tout le monde
la faire passer pour une fille ridicule
une artiste qui ne soutient pas la bonne
asos c'est ridicule et la ville nagui
pardon on s'en tape
chi chi chi le droit de donner notre
avis c'est bien qu'ils fassent à tokyo
il anime un jeu qui est un jeu de
divertissement pour qu'on rigole ou une
demande pas son avis il pourrait lancer
qui le donnent sur tout et tout le temps
parce qu'il est ce syndrome
d'aujourd'hui je suis nagui le plus
puissant il n'est pas puissant nagui
faut que jamais qu'ils oublient que quoi
qu'ils disent en parler pour l'instant
les concepts sont plus forts que lui et
un jour on saura s'en souvenir mais
mathieu ce qu'on aime chez nagui aussi
ce qui donne son avis qui rigole un peu
plus en détail un gros enjeu là quand
même on parle d'association tient certes
de l'argent ça veut dire qu'il ya des
gens qui peut être vont l'écouter et
qu'ils n'ont pas donné dans ces
associations qui est importante parce
que naguère versata sa bouche et pardon
non et ça c'est pas possible de semer le
doute sur une association avait alors
malade j'en dois vous avouer leurs
pétards oui parce que c'est ce que j'ai
fait ça il fallait faire un travail
avant se renseigne sur l'association
laon à l'antenne c'est moi je dis c'est
inconcevable de faire ça oui sur une
association surtout quand michel
personne ne va me la mets évidemment des
expérimentations de son fait pour sauver
la vie d'enfants évidemment c'est au
dessus de tout sauf que là il a bien un
peu
en disant qu' on essayait de sauver des
animaux qui dit j'ai été malade nos
rangs la maladie rend les animaux
malades et après on essayait de les
soigner
papa ils sont payés par annie la maladie
et le problème c'est que les preuves et
les expérimentations sur les animaux
servent autant pour faire des rouges à
lèvres que des médicaments c'est ça qui
est gênant je voulais qu'on n'aille pas
on n'est pas vu le truc je vous le dis
franchement avec la production et on
regarde souvent voilà ce qui se passe
sur twitter et on a vu plein de gens qui
disaient sur twitter qui parlait de
cette séquence dont on s'y intéresser on
s'est dit tiens on va en parler
aujourd'hui et on a fait une petite
compil aussi des blagues de nagui voilà
je suis assez fan des black de nagui
voilà mais il ya aussi des gens qui
disent qu'il fait trop de blagues
coquines sûr n'oubliez pas les paroles
regarder voilà et donc vous a fait une
petite compil regarde forcément il l'a
fait quatre fois puis s'est rétracté
puis je suis tombée enceinte j'avais pas
à suivre
vous êtes tombée enceinte alors qu'il
s'est rétracté j'aime bien prendre les
choses en main et donc la demande enfin
si vous êtes saxophoniste vous êtes déjà
venu dans l'émission et on avait déjà
parlé votre instrument oui parlons
maintenant du saxophone ah ouais ya du
monde au balcon et puis je peux dire que
la fenêtre elle est ouverte un donc
un meilleur rideau entre gouverneur est
ouvert c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
j'en prends
g
ce qui m'agace parce que j'ai déjà dit
je laissais commencent à sortir il a pas
d'empathie ne pense qu'à lui ne fait que
des vannes le début de son émission c 40
minutes de show nagui et là on voit
qu'elle a laissé sa carte sommes
convaincus d'être honnête je suis pas
fan de textes pour la moitié de sa tête
s'est fait virer puisque ensuite quand
il a été viré
la patronne de france télévisions
indique le vrai souci c'est pas
forcément la blague qu'il avait fait sur
un peu de ses huit c'est toutes les
blagues sexistes qui faisait pendant les
émissions qui se sont accumulés alors
pourquoi il ya deux poids deux mesures
entre les blagues sexistes et des
blagues retirer tous à 12h30 c'est drôle
mais génial daniel je me souviens que
j'ai participé à un jeu de nagui ya très
longtemps c'était que le meilleur gagne
avec des 200 oui j'étais dans les dix
dernière j'étais très jeune j'étais très
web blanche c'était ma première j'étais
noir blanc c'était la télé et on avait
gagné un petit robert et il avait parlé
de mes gros robert et va je suis désolé
ça m'avait vraiment gêné il ya très
longtemps à la longueur d'onde en ayant
gagné d'el haouz c'est gênant si cet
humour de bol de bolos moi je regarde
nagui j'aime bien cet humour un peu
comme ça j'en ai marre de la télé où tu
peux rien dire c'est que tu dis un truc
contre la raison si c'est pas grave on
attend je sais que c'est pas l'endroit
moi je suis là où je te rejoins ses
textes moi je suis pas d'accord a dit
delphine ernotte parce que tech si les
humoristes il vient à faire un sketch il
se fait jeter lui il fait tout ce qu'il
veut sébastien on lui dit que c'est un
homme 50 ans plus de 50 ans blanc ses
fans berne a plus de 50 ans bignona le
matin à plus de 50 ans elle n'est pas
cohérente dans ses propos et ayant plus
je vais même plus loin parce que arsat
est énervé les gens mais si elle avait
fait l'un vers selon elle l a dit un
homme plus de 50 ans blanc ça ne dérange
personne
je mets le truc dans l'autre sens à nome
plus de 50 ans blake les histoires
racontant il arrive lorsqu'il m'a dit tu
iras n'y a pas d'excès master dans une
interview d'accord a bien assez terne
c'est pas logique mais c'est ce qu'a dit
sir addition la semaine dernière patrick
sébastien je serai jamais d'accord avec
ça donc voilà rien c'est sûr non mais
oui mais raymond pose la question alors
est ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas par
nagui
ben je faisais d'accord c'est pas le
lieu ne s'est pas le moment et si on
évite quelqu'un pour faire la promo
d'une assoce commence pas lui chercher
des poux dans la tête c'est ça ça me
gêne après ses blagues salaces n'a pas
pour défendre à guilad
un peu dur allez on va voir du cas
peut-être les téléspectateurs voilà on
va voir ce qu'ils en pompe
oui car eh ben voilà les réalisateurs
ont défendu nagui non à 60%